hora de hablar de economía aquí en
directo América edición nocturna está
conmigo en el estudio Jorge Hurtado
Jorge muy buenas noches comenzamos
hablando de el presidente de la reserva
Federal de Estados Unidos
que abrió la puerta a su vidas en los
tipos de interés más altos bueno Esto
siempre y cuando el dato de inflación
persista la declaración deja Clara una
postura inesperadamente agresiva tomando
en cuenta la reducción de El ritmo de su
vida de tipos de interés que se había
implementado el mes pasado esta
declaración las hizo ante el congreso y
abrieron la puerta a que las autoridades
suban el tipo de interés de referencia
de la reserva Federal en medio punto
porcentual en la próxima reunión Eso sí
va a depender de los próximos informes
sobre el empleo y los precios la
reacción en los mercados los
rendimientos de los bonos a corto plazo
se dispararon las acciones cayeron y el
dólar amplió sus ganancias a nivel
global otro tema que Power abordó fue el
problema de la deuda en el turno de
preguntas de los senadores republicanos
y demócratas están discutiendo
actualmente sobre el límite del techo de
la deuda la cantidad total del dinero
que el Gobierno Federal de Estados
Unidos está autorizado a pedir prestado
para cumplir con sus obligaciones
legales existentes en la actualidad es
de 31,4 billones de dólares y fue
alcanzado el 19 de enero Powell hablará
el miércoles frente al comité de
servicio financieros de la cámara de
representantes escuchemos si parte de la
declaración de hoy
los datos de enero sobre el empleo el
gasto de los consumidores la producción
manufacturera y la inflación han
invertido las tendencias de suavización
que habíamos observado en los datos hace
apenas un mes es probable que parte de
este cambio de tendencia se deba a que
el mes de enero fue inusualmente cálido
en gran parte del país con todo la
amplitud del cambio de tendencia junto
con las revisiones del trimestre
anterior sugiere que las presiones
inflacionistas están siendo mayores de
lo previsto en la anterior reunión del
comité Federal del mercado abierto
Jorge el candidato por Estados Unidos
para dirigir el Banco Mundial está
siendo Campaña en Costa de Marfil qué
tan relevante es el voto de Costa de
Marfil bueno allá hay banca está de
visita en avillán en la primera etapa de
una Gira Mundial en la que intenta
convencer de su candidatura a los países
emergentes recordemos que ese ha sido
como parte de la apuesta de Estados
Unidos y lo pone como candidato también
tomando en cuenta su experiencia en el
sector privado para conseguir más fondo
y sobre todo su relación con los países
emergentes banca es un estadounidense de
origen indio que fue elegido por
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
para dirigir el Banco Mundial su
candidatura ya ha recibido el apoyo de
varios países emergentes como India
Kenia y gana banda Ahora tiene previsto
viajar a Kenia en la segunda etapa de
una gira que lo llevaría por todo el
mundo y parte de esta gira también de
algunas entrevistas escuchamos
Cómo no trabajar bien con un continente
que tiene tantos jóvenes cuyas
aspiraciones y optimismo nos entusiasman
a todos es lo que quiero hacer es lo que
quiero hacer el resto de mi vida quiero
ser útil quiero marcar la diferencia
creo que aporto algo de experiencia
Tengo mucho que aprender de la gente
sobre el terreno pero también de mis
colegas Bueno ya lo ven apuesta a las
economías emergentes hablemos ahora de
esa huelga en Francia que afectaron
también la distribución del combustible
en este país europeo Jorge Bueno
específicamente en la refinería de total
nergias en Londres no se esperaba que
ningún camión realizará envíos de
petróleo hasta el día viernes las
manifestaciones comenzaron Este martes
en más de 300 ciudades de toda Francia
en el marco de esta sexta jornada de
huelga nacional y protesta contra el
plan de reforma de las pensiones del
gobierno francés el presidente Manuel
macron quiere prolongar la vida laboral
pero la medida es impopular entre la
opinión pública según muestran los
sondeos los sindicatos amenazaron con
huelgas continuas que podrían durar días
Incluso en las refinerías de petróleo y
en el corte de trenes el gobierno
insiste en que su plan de reforma es
esencial para garantizar que el sistema
de pensiones no quiebre hablamos ahora
de una disputa y es la que tiene que ver
con México que está dispuesto a hacer
todo incluso ir a un panel de
controversia todo por el maíz
transgénico así lo dijo el presidente
mexicano Andrés Manuel López Obrador
Estados Unidos ya hizo una solicitud
formal de consultas en el marco del
tratado de libre comercio de América del
Norte conocido como temec por las
políticas ordenadas por el gobierno de
México sobre el uso y el comercio del
Maíz genéticamente modificado o
transgénico ya que a su juicio ponen en
riesgo las exportaciones agrícolas
estadounidenses la polémica se da luego
de que México a través de una serie de
decretos presidenciales prohibió el uso
de glifosato como herbicida para el maíz
y al mismo tiempo impidió el consumo
humano del Maíz genéticamente modificado
para Estados Unidos que es el principal
socio comercial de México el gobierno
del presidente López Obrador Busca hacer
cambios que
afectan a los exportadores
estadounidenses y amenazan según Estados
Unidos con la interrupción de miles de
millones de dólares en el comercio
agrícola y para el cierre la cifra del
día nos quedamos ahí en México porque el
producto interno bruto de ese país
podría crecer más del 15% en 2030 eso sí
si el gobierno del sector privado sumara
en el mercado laboral a 8,2 millones de
mujeres aunque esta implementación ha
estado avanzando en los últimos años Aún
es desigual según la bolsa institucional
de valores en vísperas del día de la
mujer presentó este dato tan interesante
Jorge muchas gracias por esta
actualización del mundo de la economía a
continuación hablamos de Francia en el
debate
[Música]